after three magnificent events in three
different European countries the grand
chess tour makes its triumphant return
to American soil with the 2023 St Louis
rapid and Blitz top players from around
the world will descend upon the chess
Capital to wage the ultimate war of wits
in a Race Against Time Fabiano caruana
is in Pole Position after playing two
events but will have to keep up the pace
with multiple Chasers in Hot Pursuit
crucial tour points are on the line who
will be able to out with their opponents
and Conquer The Clock follow the St
Louis chess club's twitch and YouTube
channels to tune in to live coverage of
the 2023 St Lewis rapid and Blitz
November 14th to 18th to find
out